I prepared a game to show you guys and
this is a game played by Gary cos part
of the world to form a world champion
and probably the the best player in the
history of the game in this game he's
playing another very strong head young
team on ok this game was played in 1995
about 20 21 years ago so Kasparov is
white d4 d5 c4 c6 my first question to
you is what is the name of this opening
let's see how many people here know the
name of this opening see several hands
here what's the name of this Slav
defense everyone so remember that this
is the Slav defense a very solid opening
choice for black and team undecided to
play this so as part of when Knight f3
Knight f6 Knight c3 D takes e4 this is a
very short very sharp line here black
decided to take on c4 and he wouldn't
mind to play b5 and protecting this pawn
so that's why why place a 4 simply
playing a t4 and putting pressure on d5
square trying to control that square ok
so he doesn't want to allow that ok
so he plays Bishop f5 activating the
bishop okay Bishop f5 simply activating
the bishop and trying to put pressure on
now why place 95 just trying to capture
the palm back and he does it black plays
the move 96 offering the exchange of the
Knights but white wants to keep the
knight in the middle he doesn't want to
exchange so that's why he just goes
there okay so he doesn't want to
exchange the Knights
so now
Knight B to d7 back and this is a
mistake
this is the first mistake of this game
here and Kasparov takes advantage of it
he shouldn't have played that move but
he did it and now you have a way to take
advantage of it oh you have a way to
take advantage of it
how are we gonna do that here huh let's
think very active and aggressive move
here needed to worry to put some
pressure so which move I'm referring to
here the strong active and aggressive
move here near our June Queen to b3
argent correct now what is the threat
tell us the threat dreadful all right
that's a dual threat okay double threat
here he is threatening this so now he is
basically forcing black to make you know
you need to make a good decision to
defend him otherwise he's just simply
gonna be losing it okay so he decided to
go here Knight takes e5
Knight takes e5 I decided to take pawn
takes pawn and now he goes Knight to g4
activating the night and putting some
pressure on e5 again activating the
knife and putting some pressure now what
do you think I should do here what
should be the right continuation
now what is the idea yes
yes surely for possible but also we can
put the pressure on the night right how
about we play like a spot of f4
attacking that knife now that Mike is
protecting this farm there are some
problems right nice look here and now if
you take he's gonna go Bishop d7 so I
think if it's something else here it
played something different here what did
he play dink
what did he play here
it plays very energetically here I like
that because here he does Cara was very
good at that you know he could sense the
danger in like his opponent
you know when they had a difficult
position he just immediately put a lot
of pressure on them he knew how to
develop the initiative to attack so how
did he play that here
how can you try to play here
aggressively to win this excellent job
efore attacking the bishop now Bishop
has to move to d7 to protect but you
need to continue play energetically here
to put pressure on him how are we gonna
do that how are you gonna do that how
you're going to do that here huh yes
excellent job yes pawn to f5 attacking
that night very nice attacking the
knight now the Knight has to move has to
do something so it was here now continue
with the initiative and it's developing
and attacking developing and attacking
that's what you're planning to do okay
to attack an attack now what is the idea
we have here
yes for what Bishop f4 excellent
now the knight cannot go to c4 you take
and I go in d3 you take can I go in G
six you can take so that's the problem
now this is under attack now
he goes here f6 trying to protect the
night okay he just played there now just
time to protect an eye but the really
really difficult position now for him
what do you think we should do here to
create lots of weaknesses in his
position here
you take the knight he takes
now what should be the next idea here
huh should be our next our our next idea
should be our next idea here yes you
absolutely pinning it and now at the
same time threatening what what are you
threatening to win here with continued
no you threatened to are to rocked xt7
King takes the 7 pin a that's what you
threaten ok so now I just look B at
attacking your queen what are you gonna
do to keep the same thread on to keep
the same thread on here what are you
gonna do Martin take the pawn take the
pawn first to keep it that same thread
ok if you take the bishop he takes your
Quinn you take the King he takes with
the King and it's not so clear ok keep
the pressure on now look before by young
teaming very strong Dutch Graham a
search so he's trying to put this rook
on before perhaps or do something here
this also stops Bishop c4 so why I
wanted to go Bishop c4 this will also
stop that now what are we gonna do what
are we going to do now
simply to develop our pieces remember
development is very important in any
position you want to develop your pieces
so always make sure you develop your
pieces on a good squares okay so how and
where we are going to develop it on
which squares yes you could go be spaces
but I think you have something better we
have something better than that that we
sure can go maybe somewhere else that
Bishop I feel I can go somewhere else to
create some threads
yes excellent job by Arjuna yes
threatening to publish page 5x on our
June 9th on g6 - stop it he doesn't want
to get checkmated with which page 5 so
he plays that - stop it
which movie you think you need to play
here to have all the pieces yes
yeah but what about getting the rookin
they'll be a good idea to write to get
to rockin now the rookies in the game he
could have also counseled but he
probably didn't want some checks at the
moment he already knows he's just gonna
win this game with the crushing attack
so that's why you never worry about
joseline joseline was another option
Bishop g7 and now
now what can you do here our tune
you paid rooty for because if it takes
here now what is the finish here you see
the finish data calculate calculate here
yes yeah that's that's a good move -
that might work - but here's a look at
the four ideas so maybe he's not
completely losing what about this idea
take he takes check now check you can go
to the F file so he has to go here and
now maybe you can even take this kind of
check and you win the bishop - that's a
completely willing position for you so
that's why his opponent yanti monthly
look before you try to block the
position and now what is the move here
what is the move here strong move
finishing move here
our tune
Misha page five and his opponent
resigned here because the threat of gtex
age seven is extremely powerful and the
king cannot go anywhere okay
it's extremely powerful okay so that's
why he resigned here if he lets a splays
age six to stop that idea now which move
is going to be very powerful for you to
play here which move is very very
powerful here which move is
what is the idea here
okay yes what's the move
very nice chef yes okay I have seven
activating the rock I'm putting pressure
on the bishop if you take check now you
just simply use your knife to take it
with okay now by the way you already
have a couple of extra pounds crusher is
here a lot of lot of pressure on him and
he cannot really do anything here okay
so actual position 93 95 it's coming all
right just a comfortable comfortable
position for you
93 95 and white is just winning here all
right so he resigned here so let's take
a look now at this game to see how white
one very energetically okay so okay go
ahead start the first one who who
remembers the personal go second move
name of the opening everybody in this
room should know the name of this
opening because you're gonna learn there
so this opening is called sloth defense
more confident immortal slob defense
Knight f3 Knight c3 he takes your pawn I
mentioned to you when he takes the pawn
he is trying to do something here he's
trying to do something to protect upon
are you gonna let him do that no right
what are we gonna do to prevent him from
doing that
excellent Bishop f5 now we would like to
get that phone back okay we cannot play
unfortunately for Eritrean but we have a
way to try to get the pawn back here how
we gonna try to do that Bravo
now yes
96 putting pressure on the night yes
97 yes very nice double attack
threatening checkmate and threatening
the palm b7 he takes takes Knight g4 and
now what should we do what is the Queen
doing there
yes
very nice and now now when you play very
energetically a very aggressive play by
Kasparov to win this game
yes attack in the night I'll continue
yes before now continue continue
pressing that night continue attacking
him right so it doesn't have a way to
defend you now you now you take first
remember take first now you read what
was the title Arjuna looked 87 I take my
there it goes here now back
excellent now to catch up catch up on
that development remember we're still
not that developed here guys let's catch
up on that development now
take opening up the file and letting the
rook d7 tactic with Queen eight win so
it's like if I looked afford to block
that and now yes that's it this page
five wins the game
threatening HGT xh7 made his opponent
grandmaster team and resigned because if
he was here now now our june beautiful
he check he goes here he basically has
no moves here
he's completely stuck you cannot do
anything here you can even just push
pushing getting out of Quinn that's how
dominating your position is okay we just
push push and win the game
alright okay we're gonna do one puzzle
and after this we're gonna do practice
games okay so I'm gonna pair you up with
the people around your strength all
right are you ready okay
I don't want anybody raising hands for
the next 2-3 minutes I want everybody
just to calculate variations okay and
this is a position where it looks like
completely draw because opposite call up
bishops
I mean pawn versus pawn bishop I mean it
just doesn't look like there is anything
so but you're gonna be able to find a
way to win this game okay you're gonna
be able to do that okay huh it's whose
turn is it first white to play and
checkmate in I believe one two three
four five six seven eight yeah but it's
not so difficult now hands down hands
down guys thinking a little bit hands
down everybody
think for a few minutes I want you to
have the entire thing entire thing not
just a little bit of it okay you need to
have the entire line okay then we can
say you have this the entire thing you
have
all right you get the first chance go
correct correct
ie ie ie let me escape I see I want to
lose my pawn actually you can only win
this because of the pun you first two
moves are correct but then you rushed it
you rushed it here you don't you don't
want c6 to happen here who can see the
rest of the six moves here the rest of
the six moves to have the solution you
okay control we got a control here
remember in the back correct
now if it moves the bishop you go
checkmate okay so he has to go here what
are you gonna do push the pawn
now we need to activate this bishop I
believe yes correct
r-truth it's wrong why not define stage
smaller stay in the center centralize
the pieces okay now he has to go here
and now what is the idea huh what is the
idea yes
you push the fun yes check me excellent
any questions that's it you cannot do
anything and you win the game okay that
is your solution okay very good okay so
let's do this one one more time so so
everybody can understand this so you
start with the check he goes back r2 now
this is a difficult move this one some
of you missed it yes fixing it fixing
the squares okay
and the pawn so he cannot push it so he
goes here now control control excellent
now no no it's good enough now put the
pawn now let's try to do something else
now centralize our bishop right how
correct now he goes here next one and
now what are we gonna do Tom posh he
takes it checkmate excellent job any
questions anybody no perfect very good
now I'm gonna pair you up with some
opponents okay